no se abrirán las puertas del sueño
americano tras la expiración del título
42 el 11 de mayo
Déjenme ser claro nuestra frontera no
está abierta y no estará abierta después
del 11 de mayo lo que estamos anunciando
es la expansión de nuestro plan para
construir caminos legales e imponer
consecuencias Para quienes no usen esos
Caminos con la incertidumbre de si la
oferta cubrirá la demanda la expansión
de nuevas vías legales anunciadas por la
administración biden se suma a los cupos
habilitados ya a venezolanos cubanos
haitianos y nicaragüenses si tienen un
familiar o patrocinador estadounidense
una política que ahora se abre a
personas de Colombia Guatemala El
Salvador y Honduras por otro lado
Washington abrirá nuevos centros de
procesamiento de solicitudes de asilo y
visados en Guatemala y Colombia e
intentará derivar a migrantes hacia
España y Canadá a pesar de que cuando
caiga el título 42 impuesto por la
administración Trump durante la pandemia
de 2019 el pretexto de amenazas
sanitaria no servirá para justificar las
expulsiones inmediatas de las personas
que crucen y regularmente las fronteras
el secretario de seguridad nacional
aclaró que las devoluciones a México no
se detendrán aquellos que lleguen a
nuestra frontera sin una base legal para
quedarse habrán hecho el camino a menudo
sufriendo traumas y pagando todos sus
ahorros a los traficantes solo para ser
devueltos rápidamente serán expulsados
en cuestión de días o de unas semanas la
restricciones impuestas por el título 42
se levantaron excepcionalmente para los
ucranianos mientras varias ong
denunciaron que a personas de otros
orígenes se les negaba el derecho
internacional al asilo en todo caso la
medida no impidió las cifras récord en
el año fiscal de 2022 cuando las
autoridades de Estados Unidos detuvieron
a más de 2,5 millones de personas que
intentaron llegar al país que recibe más
migrantes internacionales del mundo
cruzando una de las fronteras
más peligrosas del planeta